you guys stop copy I was I was I was by
myself with a clap in their thing
alright everybody good morning good
morning gratitude journal live stream
number 21 coming at you it is
Thanksgiving here in Canada so we have a
delayed start doing some family stuff
and I have two special guests with me
today who are you guys hey danina so
we're going to start this is a daily
thing we do three things that you're
grateful for ah normally I share three
things but today we're going to have
Hayden share one thing Nina share one
thing and I'm going to share one thing
and then you guys watching live share it
down limit on the side of the chat and
people watching have to share it in the
comments below two most important things
and my voice cracked it's consistent it
its daily it's regular part of your
routine it's not just something that you
do once in a while and 2 the and two
that you really feel it so ask yourself
why why why is why you grateful for not
just listing things off okay so we're
going to get started and then we'll do
some shout outs in the check for the
people who are leaving comments there
first up is mr Hayden what do you before
and why I hate families and why and
because if we didn't have that way I
wouldn't be alive right now there you go
I like it grateful for family because if
we didn't that family wouldn't be alive
good job mr. high five okay Nina um I'm
riffle for your parents actually we were
we were kind of sick yesterday we're
supposed to have Thanksgiving dinner
together but then they're going on a
trip suits so we didn't want to get them
sick but um your parents the his parents
thought you brought food over for us to
to eat yeah very thoughtful that is good
yeah I'm grateful
I'm grateful for these for these people
they're very special to me and I like
whenever I can spend time with them I
what was that mr. baby okay let's do
some let's diss record yeah we're still
a little sick let's do how much time we
got six minutes I gotta be able to check
the clock here so we end on time let's
let's check out the chat do some
shoutouts who do we have we've got a
bunch of chatter cuz we're late welcome
Rishi welcome much welcome your future
builder welcome Jay rise hi welcome
sherry sherry is grateful for believe
nation that pulls me through anything me
what else what else what else you can't
to other microphone here a little bit
over okay you can see that now hello
most of it anymore not good good I want
to be able to see the side here good
okay what else what else what else that
Rishi he's probably eating turkey right
now actually connect her down we had
sushi we had sushi turkey for breakfast
decided quarter zeno is grateful for
churros me and my mom just ate some at
the fair I love that what else is there
a game after this is no game after this
you should G rise no no usually I do
extreme this is the only stream of the
day the only she was a junior is a no
grateful for my teammates stepping up
and playing a pretty good game while I
was hurt good job Zeno's also good
before a friend that I got to know to
the power of the internet who I talked
to Daily and I watched movies and series
with you guys don't know her but she's
awesome she she is awesome and for those
of you who left gratitude comments
before we started put them back because
YouTube chat disappears and solo I
didn't see them I started from what I
saw what else what else what else what
else what else what else what else a
bunch of chatter chatter chatter hashtag
kept a good day
but Papa thought thought up above
thought shopman oh there we go there we
go okay good morning got the
notification good morning hello Sonia
Sarah Kevin grateful for another day
sabrine happy thanksgiving thank you
very kindly now we hi everybody rom
hello or young god this is great nice to
see y'all let's just see three of you
we're switching it up today Stassi I
Stacy Oh ribbon for my voice to sing
sounds good to me can you say oh it's
pretty good Sarah people for your dr.
Wayne Dyer four hours video just
finished listening to it this morning
while I was driving it's a good video
Greipel for the French bakery in the
next town beautiful for having this day
I love it Kevin grateful grateful to see
the people of YouTube I love it the Shan
tube I'm grateful that I'm coming back
from such a peaceful vacation although
the odds were against me I don't know
what happened on vacation but glad
you're back Kevin is grateful for
grateful for life to be able to achieve
my goals the chain tube oh wait we did
the chain tube boo Yong God grateful for
God and True Parents Alex good morning
what's up Alex grateful for my
motivation because it really changed my
life and helped me every area of my life
to have a happier cause of my life
career and healthier life what's
happening with you guys I love it Alex
Yvonne people for the Chris Gardner
video from the UK happy thanksgiving is
it Thanksgiving me UK too I don't know
is it Thanksgiving for you guys this
right I've Blue Jays one last night
super excited we're off to the next
round I was jumping up and down Nina had
a face mask on and was it showing
emotion but she was feeling it she was
having on the inside uh Susan is glad to
know but thanks giving us a month away
not in Canada it's today
thiet in November yeah I know in the US
is in November a grateful for humanities
amazing future I like that we all got
stepping up oh I didn't count thank you
serene I missed you serene Nina just
pointed out we got recognized serene
grateful for bang mates stepping up and
believing in us i love that Kevin
grateful to be grateful good sabrine
ungrateful for my family and the great
things that God granted me Chris people
have caught your broadcast to be on live
with you Evan all right everybody's
grateful to be on live watching with us
Jacob grateful for oh good what did I
miss no that's it Jacob grateful for a
piano to play on my lunch break you can
play some piano today yeah that the
tally Natalie vitali Natalie grateful
for being able to be here heart we're
grateful you could be here to know we
grateful for my beautiful wife I'm here
for my beautiful wife to Chris women for
the Cubs victories so much fun congrats
to you in your JS feeling at Chris Cubs
JS files let's see what happens I'm with
you until we get to the finals Yvonne
you Kate doesn't have any thanksgiving
day wow that's pretty sad no
thanksgiving day we got to talk to
Stephen Kelly make that happen we are
grateful for my family giving giving
given by God Chris paper for sunny clear
days helps me be positive that's three I
love it well thank you guys we're gonna
continue on with our day we have some
Thanksgiving fun planned thank you for
joining us even though it was a late
start any final message mr. no no what
do you want to tell everybody an
important reminder
that was my reminder whoa whoa do some
whoa today this something that makes you
go whoa today I like it mr. Krieger mind
they're all right let's say guys have an
awesome day have a great start to the
week continue to believe or whatever
your one more days llz soon yeah we will